[Music]
migrants run amok in a total cluster
situation
more than a thousand migrants mostly
Venezuelans late for spring training
storm to bridge linking Mexico to the
United States and El Paso Texas on
Sunday they were so desperate to enter
Texas you'd think they were Californians
videos detailing the chaos that unfolded
migrants of all ages charging forward
pouring in from all sides trying to get
into the land of Freedom opportunity and
pancakes and not because they heard Greg
was washing his car in jean shorts again
I haven't seen such commotion since I
tried to withdraw my savings from
Silicon Valley Bank
the situation got so chaotic Customs and
Border Protection had to beef up
Manpower on the U.S side of the bridge
while the Mexican military tried to
contain things on their side it looked
like the New York City marathon minus
all the paperwork beforehand
meanwhile White House Press Secretary
Karine Jean-Pierre recognizing the
nation's obesity problems so she served
up another word salad hit it girl
we're gonna move forward with a with a
uh with this kind of system this
immigration system that has been gutted
really truly gutted by the last
Administration we're going to move
forward and do it in a humane way we're
going to do it in a safe way uh and
we're going to do it in the way that
moves us forward and so what we have
been seeing what we've been dealing with
again is trying to fix the damage that
the last Administration do did
here's an actual video of the brain
cells leaving her head during that
statement
folks Kareem Jean-Pierre is so dumb she
almost froze to death at a drive-in
movie
she had gone to see closed for the
winter
[Laughter]
sit next to somebody slow help them out
with that one
what do you mean I've never heard of
that
uh Ali I will start with you uh we're
all worked up about this but as someone
who has slept with a lot of illegals are
we missing the point
yeah bring them over get them over here
for us no we have to stop this I mean
they're basically being told that our
policy is Red Rover Red Rover and if you
get over here you can stay you get given
I mean I want to be an illegal immigrant
they're getting hotel rooms debit cards
sometimes you get a free trip to
Martha's Vineyard you know
it's a crazy situation I I think
everybody agrees Kat let me ask you this
though because you told a famous Story
Once about having a boyfriend who you
couldn't get out of your apartment yeah
he wasn't my boyfriend whoever he had
stopped being your boyfriend I think he
was but he had stayed yeah is
deportation the problem in this era
because it doesn't look compassionate so
you've just got to let them stay
shocking what people will do for access
to in-unit laundry
I tried so hard I was like you have to
go all of a sudden his foot's injured it
was bad
onwards and upwards Molly I will ask you
if you had to go away for the weekend
and leave your kids with one person
Karine Jean-Pierre or Kamala Harris
what do you do it is I was just thinking
listening to her she sounds just like
Kamala Harris and you remember like
during the Trump era you had all of
these like highly competent press
secretaries and the media would be
losing their minds you know they'd shout
a question that was angry they'd get a
good response and they would just scream
in response we've been dealing with this
for years now it's embarrassing like
it's embarrassing as an American I'm
embarrassed for her she's a lovely lady
but she should not be in this job and
it's it's just what what's going on like
I feel like I'm taking crazy pills that
we keep letting this happen but it's
this every day she didn't say nothing
she said we're working on it and it's so
hard because Trump messed it up yes
that's I mean that's of course right
that's that's not what happened you know
there's very many issues that are
involved with this but she took 40
seconds to say it because the longer you
talk you think maybe just based on how
long she was talking that she said more
than that I think that's what's going on
in her head but you know because this is
all about empower government maybe she's
good at her job because she's making the
rest of the country feel like they're
empowered and they could be press
secretary too I hadn't thought about
that yeah I mean don't you watch her and
walk away being like I could have did
that yeah yeah like but he but he but he
a path to a path
sounds great to me yeah just keep
talking Kareem jumpier ah Karine she
dresses nice that's a nice thing I've
got two nice things to say about this
Administration she does dress nice and
Joe Biden dress is nice he does he does
that's it that's the only nice thing
I've ever seen no I like the way he does
the Versace diaper
is good yeah I agree
Jimmy
uh Molly you're an editor can you edit
that statement
I don't even know I just want say too
like this idea of blaming Donald Trump
the Trump Administration was not perfect
and it wasn't Perfect On the Border but
they actually did get to the point where
the Border was somewhat under control
yeah and President Biden like on day one
moved to tear down every protection and
now when things like this happen they're
like why is this happening we have no
idea what's going on
no that's the scam you see remember the
old Chris Rock bit where he talks about
Robitussin he's like you know you got a
bullet wound pull a little Tussin on it
you know what I mean that whole thing I
think Trump is Democrat Robitussin in
this day and age they've got to border
problem get a little Tussing yeah I mean
inflation get a little touching it's not
cultural appropriation relax everybody's
fine um stick with me do you think what
happened is they got used to playing a
card that just doesn't work anymore I
don't know if it doesn't work I think it
still works for their base I think if
you blame Trump for everything people
you know they go with it and I think
Publications love it they love
mentioning Trump he gets ratings so
whenever they can they invoke Trump for
sure and she just does this version of
Abbott and Costello where you don't
you're like who what is going on you
can't follow it and she brings up Trump
oh yeah he's to blame oh there you go
there it is that's scary because it's
like we're bumper bowling for these
people you know when you have a slow kid
so you block the gutters just to make
sure they don't throw it in the gutter
yeah but they're just throwing it over
into the next Lane now instead yeah it's
embarrassing hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else